[Music]
so I know some of you guys listened to
the Joe Rogan podcast so that means you
must know who Lhari ship furious yes we
heard we know what this isn't and I
didn't hear okay so for Joe and those of
you who haven't heard
Ari Shaffir is a comic and he posted on
his social media this is what he looks
like
first of all who's his face and he
posted this video and you can judge it
for yourself well as this Instagram yes
here you guys I know there's always a
lot of like hate pain in the world so as
much terrible stories every once in a
while there's a good story good story
comes out the guy who got away with rape
got his today Kobe Bryant is gone I'm
here in Charlotte the Homewood team that
originally drafted him maybe wouldn't
that chicken never is even if it stayed
in show with the Hornets anyway the
point is too soon this was literally
like the nickname I know it's a bit it
was the same thing I could always the
same day the same day because I read his
statement after he says he releases like
he says [ __ ] oh [ __ ] about people that
diaries actual statement um where is it
okay
every time a beloved celebrity diets I
post some horrible [ __ ] about them I've
been doing it for years now
I like destroying gods and right when a
famous person dies they're at their most
worshiped so as a response to all the
outpouring of sympathy on social media I
post something vile it's just a joke I
don't really hate any of these people
he's right I mean I know what he's
saying
destroying God's like he's saying that
we all do too much to prop people up
when they die right we we make them
Olympians we make them [ __ ] statue
like [ __ ] atlas we put the world on
their back and say they held it all up
but he's saying that's silly he's such a
tattletale though like III get what do
you mean the town council well he's like
he's like not he's like one of those
guys that are like hold on guys let me
bring it back to reality
I know shut the [ __ ] up do you let
people happy people are mourning so that
the part that I feel like might be like
it's a bit and I get his angle but I
think the part that he might be
insensitive to are there really people
that are close to him that are mourning
and so what to him hit as a comedian
he's like so what I'm just doing a bit
in mind no one's safe in my lane right
no one's safe and like it's over here
I'm not tweeting this at Kobe Bryant's
family yeah yeah I'm saying this in my
lane to my people and then the people
who are pissed are not Ari Shaffir fans
are [ __ ] randos had never heard of
are you sure he was also saying like
he's like I do this all the time I
always those fans get it on his instant
always his fans gay but at the same time
you do something like that in public and
on and especially about a celebrity as
big as Kobe Bryant I mean of course you
gotta expect you know I'm saying Kobe
Bryant fans to be mad at you for that
and I agree you you open yourself up to
that OS yeah so there's this New York
Times piece around this whole situation
here and they're pointing out the fact
that this guy he there's this like not
as prevalent type of comedy that is now
becoming prevalent is the troll like the
trolling kind of comedy where the whole
the whole joke is the fact that people
are upset right that's the joke that's
okay
yeah and so they're just highlighting
how this dude is like you know that that
was his angle but bottom line if you're
gonna do that you're on a public
platform yeah don't be surprised if you
offend people yeah so what ended up
happening is he got dropped from his
management oh really yes
there's some real consequences and he's
also like cuz he then his Netflix
special get canceled damn yeah this to
me
it makes him braver than most right
because then look I know I understand I
was sensitive to the Chloe thing too I
understand what the counterpoint is but
he's braver than most because he's
willing to say the thing that people
won't say and that's what George Carlin
did when he was making fun of [ __ ]
Christians and getting [ __ ] cops
called on him and
having getting thrown out of
amphitheaters in the 70s and 80s right
but Carlin I think the slight
differences condom is making big points
he was making fun of society well this
one I don't know what the this one seems
more self-righteous yeah I don't know
what the real point hey guys no one no
one's a guy but let me bring everyone
down
let's also point out in justices - no
but it's good look
Kobe died Kobe died and Kobe's now
statue that has no scars no no tarnishes
no blend no blemishes right and that's
that's what he's doing here he's saying
there were blemishes
he isn't Kobe's not a god ko he's not
this [ __ ] monolithic figure Kobe had
a flaws that's what that's what I think
his construction is like that's all yeah
I'm just devil's advocate in this I also
believe that - so I like I mean so I saw
I saw your post and I got what you were
doing I got it people who pissed about
what you're doing but I got it right
well it wasn't about okay so I okay go
ahead okay his boss was like he was
posting about about he started posting
my helicopters right and it was
basically and people were pissed that
you were even posting my helicopters but
like you were saying like you know now
all of a sudden something happens you
want to post about your like buggy an
appreciation for helicopter might know
my disdain your position for land right
because it was like you were making fun
of the fact that a lot of people that
like would never talk about Kobe now
that there's a death they want to post
about Kobe it's about them so I got a
joke is not on Kobe exactly I get or his
family or anybody and it but for him I
get what you're saying I get what he's
doing but like you know but like we're
all saying like when you when you do a
joke like this in the way that he did it
you run a risk of pissing off a lot of
people always and that will have
consequences and in this case it had big
consequences you know because a lot of
people were like not just offended
they're like a man can't be surprised if
[ __ ] like that goes yeah yeah you know
definitely not yeah definitely yeah so
do you guys know who Tony Hinchcliffe
yes so he's another comic and he ended
up tweeting Kobe passing this can't be
true
so a risky joke based off of the fact
that he has a reputation for hogging the
ball right yeah
you know yeah that's kind of funny he
did receive push back and he offended
people but since it wasn't but that is
also more clever than what all right cuz
Arthur said today we thank goodness he's
gone but I view the intent really I
understand it's a better line the
situation wasn't very good yeah yeah
this bit wasn't clever and I get where
you're trying to get out with the bit I
think was still workshopping it but it
just wasn't executed properly yeah and
so I guess that's the reason why for a
lot of people like this didn't make
headlines like Ari Shaffir and him
getting dropped and stuff in getting
things cancelled there's a lot of people
got the joke yeah because I think it's
clearly a joke but the whole trolling
aspect this is like a new thing where
it's like what your joke is to piss us
off like that's [ __ ] I don't know if
it's necessarily new I think it's nice
to the people that understand they get
the joke that's the whole trolling
aspect of it is like yeah but the thing
about Charlie know is that if you piss
off the rigid people like how Christians
used to get pissed off because it had
stick up sticks up their asses
you piss those people off its mission
accomplished so if you can piss off the
people in society who take them so
seriously mission accomplished
but then there are consequences of that
right people are actually pissed you're
choking the cancer lifeline gets cut off
right so [ __ ] like that that sucks right
then that's the risk
so it's both yeah that's the hill he
wants to die on and like cool but are we
cool with that like are we all cool with
him dying on that hill are we all down
with that that's that's the question and
I don't know that I think so I don't
think so I feel like you know Layton for
me intent matters if it was Timmy
delaghetto or anybody else I'd be down
with that but that's my predisposition
right I'm pretty down with being
flexible towards whatever it is even if
you joke about me all the time like you
know when I die I was like I don't want
people to say that was too soon like you
I like you'll go in you know I'm saying
like make make jokes about me make make
make death jokes about me as long as
they're funny
you feel me exactly I'm with you and so
it's like I feel like that I don't know
for him I feel like there was no joke
there
a lot because he's niche a lot of people
don't know who the [ __ ] he is like I
didn't really know who he was and it
just I didn't get the joke but that's
why I listen to the outrage that sounds
sad is the joke it's questioned on it's
questionable because his real fans that
was a joke for his fans not for us who
maybe don't follow him or like the
people who don't follow him like you
like what people were saying it's like
if this is a joke for your fans then you
could be putting it in a podcast or
whatever the [ __ ] like I guess more than
his social media for sure yeah I would
have still leaked out right that means
maybe some of his fans didn't even like
it it has spread it to other people I
don't love that I don't like the joke
but I'm defending it because I know what
he meant to do which was joke and that's
all and I think that this hold this diss
old-world thinking of like hey it's not
okay to joke about some things is like
an old judeo-christian [ __ ] thing to
do and I don't like that [ __ ] and to me
that's where that that's where that all
started and so when I hear this now in
are they're placing a hand over your
mouth and yourself over over they over
his mouth I mean yeah in general well I
think that's cool but like for me right
like like I really enjoy music and I
love music and I try to listen to as
much music as possible but things that I
don't understand because I guess my my
music IQ is low when I listen to jazz
I'm confused and I'm like I don't get it
but someone that understands what's
really going on they're like wow like
they it's so intricate or did you hear
how that happened or like all this chaos
I don't tell you don't tell a jazz
resistance to stop playing right right
right right
but but but because of that it's like it
I don't listen to you cuz I don't
understand it you know like it goes
above my head something like this it's
like it's like you kind of like I'm not
gonna get it so like I don't understand
that it's a joke so that's why I didn't
get but that's the risk of social in
terms of freedom of speech I'm with
Steve I mean freedom of jokes I'm with
Steve where everyone should play the
tune to their band their own band yeah
and you play your own tune if your own
followers love you that that's how it is
so I think like if he's not for me I
wouldn't have like in my world I
wouldn't have counseled the more cats
like right cuz he if he wants to tell
those type of jokes and there's people
that actually enjoy them let them
like don't cut it as lifeline yeah I
don't know about that because for me
it's all about if you run the risk of
playing with fire there's there's common
there's there's current sense right and
if you know that if someone's morning
and you make a make fun of of whoever
they're mourning for obviously they're
gonna hate you for it right so if you
want to play with that fire and then you
get mad at the fact that someone's hurt
by the fact that they're mourning about
someone you make fun of that figure and
then you don't feel like you're in the
wrong for doing that because you have
the right to do so
but to me if you're an [ __ ] you have
the right to be punished by by by not by
illegal and not by legality right
obviously but if a company goes hey that
doesn't stick with our brand we don't
like having guys like that in our brand
and they decide to kick them off or if
the people turn around and say hey [ __ ]
you you hurt my feelings that's okay -
yeah also - I don't think that he is
sitting there going I'm pissed that
everyone's pissed at me yeah I haven't
seen that I think I've seen him doubling
down on this [ __ ] if anything as a count
or something yeah he started doing [ __ ]
to his social media and stuff cuz I
think there is the whole like what do
you call it like everyone getting their
pitchforks and mob mentality that
happens but I think if you want to be
risky you run the risk of that happening
always whenever you do anything but is
it illegal though I don't think you
should you know I think to your point
about the management I think that sucks
that they dropped him because it's like
you already know what you're kind of
getting you you know we something do
understand that it is a money game and
like at the end of the day it's all
about the bottom line right but like for
the management to like turn their back
on him - I think it's pretty [ __ ] up
but it's a business move really is in
money right it's all bottom at the end
of the day I don't think that even what
the people on the farthest side of [ __ ]
Ari Shaffir are saying is like he should
be legally banned I think it's more like
they're personally offended and like get
this off of my feed kind of [ __ ] yeah
but like that's what I'm saying is like
don't follow him don't like that's all
yeah if I if I saw that and I didn't
know who the guy was up now [ __ ] this
guy yeah right I move on I don't know if
people know how to not engage in this
society today with social media they
to say their opinion yeah it's just
think but for me I agree with you you're
saying but I think for me I would like
to see the chips fall so the management
if you sign are I should fear you know
the type of humour he has so you should
get us back and it does more re [ __ ] get
us back even more and let the chips fall
the way down where if he does have his
Netflix special if there's two people in
the audience then that's the real
consequence but they're erasing there
let they're erasing the entire like
letting it go all the way down and play
it out all the way I'm just glad that
when the majority of the country thought
something George Carlin could not be
banned no matter what right and that
voice was allowed to inform a many many
people through laughter and so this
isn't the best example of that but I
think that it should exist because even
though I'm challenging is the joke it at
least challenges people's stupid [ __ ]
perspectives sometimes and that's good
that's good we should always be
challenged to think a different way and
see things in a different in a different
light absolutely and it's like it's not
a good bit right and I feel like you
know what maybe they weren't even like I
feel like maybe they just said there
can't there they ended their
relationship just to save face for
social media and they probably you know
our move you know yeah the Netflix
special might come up after a month
because people want to see him fail like
he'll be back he'll do notice he'll do
one for trust me
[Music]
[Music]